let's get some sweet tips and recipes
please welcome
my new friend beautiful leo the shirley
temple king himself hi leo
hi how are you today great how are you
tell me leo why are you the shirley
temple king
well i love soy temples because i love
it's like the explosion in my mouth i
love the sparks from the grenadine
the sweetness from the ginger ale and
the garnishes
let me ask you a question what do you do
if you don't like the shirley temple
oh i take one teensy sip and then i
wouldn't drink it for the rest of the
day
like one time i said i'd give it a one
to be kind instead of doing it as zero
but still it's a low score
well you know i think it's hard to take
people's reviews seriously unless
they're honest but sometimes being
honest is hard
yeah what's your favorite shirley temple
where well i
actually went to new york and i stayed
there for a little christmas vacation
and santa came and he gave me shirley
temple and cookies
so i rated that one to ten so that was
probably my best really temple
who would have thought that santa claus
would make the best shirley temple
speaking of
let's make a shirley temple can we walk
me through it
yeah get the palms hot so sun so i
love ice i like my ice to be fancy
shmanchi
so sometimes i use cubed ice sometimes i
use
crushed ice sometimes there's these even
these spears of ice
so those are cool so i obviously got my
ice in the
um the glass cup because i don't like
plastic it's bad for the environment
good so i'm gonna take my ginger ale now
people might be asking
leo why use ginger ale when you can have
lemon lime soda
because a i don't like lemon lime soda
and b is not the classic way to make
chili temples
you're a purist thank you
[Applause]
so then i'll take the grenadine i only
want to do a splash of it
maybe a little bit more just to make it
not pink and not too bright red
just a splash dash splash dash got it
yeah
and did you know fun fact about
grenadine did you know that it's
actually made with pomegranate you think
it's cheery but it's actually
pomegranate
really and pomegranates are really
healthy yeah they are good
i'm sure they're still healthy with the
eight pounds of sugar that they've put
on the pomegranate yeah
take the cherries so i use three
cherries now you might be wondering why
three because if you eat one you're
gonna be like well i
ate one now i have no more and then
you'd be like
oh come on i ate it so
i like three and then that's how to make
your shirley temple all right let's have
a sip ready
uh social distance cheers to you
oh my god dude that rocks
thank you ah yeah everybody leo the
shirley temple king thank you so much
for coming
you